foreign
[Music]
and I'm very very sorry for that the AC
unit that uh cools this room is out so
we're trying to funnel air from all the
other rooms in here
so bear with us we did provide everybody
with a complimentary fan
that also doubles as read along with our
benediction at the end of the service
yay so fan all you want fan all you want
it will help I promise
um
and I just have a couple of
announcements and things coming up
things to be aware of here at the table
uh first of all we have our samarama
kids camp coming up yay it is coming up
this this coming Friday and Saturday so
if you have kiddos kindergarten through
sixth grade you're not going to want to
miss that make sure you sign them up
sign up forms are on our website also if
you would like to volunteer we need more
volunteers so we would love to have you
do that you can sign up to be a
volunteer also on our website one of the
big changes we want to let you know
about is Friday the start time will be 5
p.m I think originally it was two it's
going to be 5 P.M to 8 30 p.m on Friday
okay and then this the normal hours for
Saturday so if you have any questions
Brittany can you raise your hand
Brittany over here we'll answer any
questions you have about that but
summerama is coming up and it's going to
be fun
yay secondly
this is the last Sunday of July that
means that next Sunday we have our first
Sunday meal at hat Creek Burger Company
in Sachse so just want to let you know
we'll be getting back into all of our
regular rhythms after chilling out a bit
in July so please please especially if
you're new uh come join us at hat Creek
Burger Company next Sunday immediately
after the service
we'd love to have you there
um as I mentioned July has been more of
a chill month around here and that is by
Design our pastor Brett takes the month
off to refresh and rest he pours out so
much for this community and he works
really really hard and so July is the
time for him to step back refresh
remember that God is God and he is not
and we are not and it's just it's a good
time to rest and we really really
believe in rest rhythms around here
otherwise we'd all just burn out and
that's no fun so
um also during the month of July we've
had so many wonderful guest speakers we
had Jesse last week we had Lori pravin
we had Miriam who did our panel
interview so I and we have Megan and
Christian tonight or who again who are
going to be amazing
um so I just wanted to take a moment to
thank all of our guest speakers that
we've had in July it's been such a treat
and a gift to have you here
um
so with that said
let's downshift ourselves a bit let's
Center ourselves
for worship so many of us are go go go
in our heads a lot life is spinning
let's take a moment just to calm our
hearts and our minds
if it's helpful take some deep breaths
close your eyes
and just be here now
the hard part is over you got here
just rest and be and receive
let's pray
God thank you for tonight thank you for
this time together
thank you for fans
and I pray your blessings over each
person here each person who's watching
or listening online God
I pray your peace and Grace and love
upon them help us to open our hearts and
our minds
to your love your encouragement and your
presence tonight
help us to remember that we're not alone
and whatever we're going through
and that you are a firm foundation
in Jesus name amen
amen thanks Karen why don't you guys get
up off those cloth sweaty seats
and we're we're gonna spend some time
singing together
um I am so grateful for this opportunity
that we get each time that we come
together to spend a little bit of time
um worshiping and for that that's
opening up a space a creative space to
interact with God and as a community
together to speak out some of the things
that we believe are true about who he is
so you guys join in with that and if
there are pieces of the song If there
are lyrics that ring especially true to
you tonight I just invite you to open up
your hands or close your eyes
um or sing them out um but feel free in
your expression to connect with the
things that are naturally connecting and
give God space and ask him what where
are you in this for me what are you
speaking to me because I believe he's
here and he's wanting to connect with us
as we connect with one another so so
there's room and space to do that
we're going to start with a song called
Psalm 116 and it's literally ripped some
of the words right out of that passage
in the Bible
um so let's join in together and and
speak out this truth that has been said
about God for Generations now and
connect with that deeper that deeper
message
foreign
[Music]
for you have delivered me
I love you Lord
who have delivered my soul from Death my
feet from stumbling I will walk in the
land of the living my soul from Death my
feet from stumbling now we walk in the
land of the living
[Music]
thank you
let's sing that again I love you Lord
I love you Lord for you have delivered
me
my soul from Death my feet from
stumbling
[Music]
my soul from my feet from stumbling I
will walk in the land of the living
let's go
[Music]
sing I'll bless you Lord I Will Bless
You Lord
who hurt my cry I reached out my hand
and you saved my life I will bless you
Lord for you heard my plea and the god
of Heaven turned his ear to me I Will
Bless You Lord forever
[Music]
I will call on you as long as I may live
I love you Lord
for you have delivered me
for you have lived my soul from Death
from stumbling I will walk in the lands
of the living my soul from Death my feet
from stumbling I will walk in the land
of the living
thank you guys for starting that off
we're going to go ahead and dismiss our
kids to their classrooms so if you are
first grade and under you're going to
come up here to this front classroom on
my left and you older school age kids
can come over here to my right
[Music]
thank you kids for joining us
foreign
we're going to move into the prayers of
the people and for those of you that are
joining us for the first time this is an
opportunity for us to lift up the things
that we're carrying into this space the
things that are weighing on our hearts
maybe someone that you know that you are
praying for or that your heart is
burdened for or a situation that's
Weighing on you we want to lift those up
together believing that God is hearing
us that he is with us that he loves us
and sees us even in our pain
so um we're going to go ahead and have
Noel lead us and I just before she does
I need to say Noel is about to leave for
college this is her final Sunday on
stage with us as like a regular rotation
um we are yes let's just let's give her
a hand
[Applause]
um she was one of our graduates this
Sunday and I mean this summer and I have
just been counting down each Sunday that
I know as it's going on and on
um knowing we're drawing to an end of a
season and it's really special for us
because the table was a startup church
and we started with just a handful of
families and Noel has been such a
faithful part of our community both on
this team with our youth team with a
girls small group and we just love her
we love you and we've loved her being a
part of this and so very appropriately
she is going to lead the prayers of the
people tonight and um I just wanted to
take a second in the midst of our
worship to honor her because
um worship is beautiful as a community
and she is a value part of this
community so
I won't say anything else but
um you guys read along with Noel as she
leads us in this prayer
[Music]
for the city of Sachse Texas and for
every city and community and all who
live in them we pray to you
for The Good Earth you have given us and
the wisdom and will to conserve it we
pray to you for the old and the sick for
the Widow and orphan for the injured and
suffering we pray to you
for the poor and the oppressed the
unemployed and destitute for prisoners
and captives and all who remember and
care for them we pray to you
for the vulnerable the marginalized and
those unjustly targeted for their gender
sexuality race or other perceived
difference we pray to you
for those experiencing lost loneliness
and disconnection and for those
struggling with mental and emotional
health we pray to you
Lord we know that you love us and that
you hear us
so we lift these names and situations up
to you
see
[Music]
Ryan and Steph
thank you
foreign
for the names and moments we have spoken
aloud and for those we have kept in our
hearts we pray to you and that they may
have life and light healing and a hope
peace and a deep sense of your presence
amen
[Music]
thank you
spending out of control I feel it losing
my
[Music]
fences know it tonight
ending go and
trusting you
so I will stop
breathe rest here in your goodness I
know you won't leave it's my confidence
I will stop
breathe rest here in your goodness I
know you won't
it's my confidence
[Music]
spinning
spinning out of control I feel it losing
money
fences no it's not easy
[Music]
oh
trust in you
so I will stop
breathe rest here in your goodness I
know you only it's my confidence
I will stop
breathe rest here in your goodness I
know you won't believe it's my
confidence here I am so here I am
[Music]
nothing can take me away nothing can
take me away
here I am in the palm of your head
nothing can take me away nothing can
take me I sing that one more time
here I am
in the palm of your head nothing can
take me away no nothing can take me away
here I am in the palm of your head
nothing can take me away nothing can
take me away
[Music]
nothing can take me away
not a high or a death
not a lie inside my head not a fear or
offense nothing can take me away
not a hide or a dance not a lie inside
my head not a fear or offense nothing
can take me away
[Music]
nothing can take me away
sing here I am
so here I
apologize
nothing can take me away
here I am in the palm of your head
nothing can take me away nothing can
take me away it's my confidence
he's my confidence
it's my confidence confidence it's my
confidence
it's my confidence
[Music]
nothing can take me away
in Psalm 136 it says give thanks to the
Lord for he is good his love endures
forever
give thanks to the god of Gods
his love endures forever give thanks to
the Lord of lords
his love endures forever
to the one who remembered us
to the one who freed us from our enemies
his love endures forever
to him who gives food to every creature
give thanks to the god of Heaven
his love endures forever
see two three four
[Music]
you broke my chains of sin and shame and
you covered me with Grace
human my life with your Holy Fire you
cover me with Grace
you are the hand that reaches outside
I am set free
oh
it is for Freedom
that I am
set free
foreign
[Music]
it is
oh
I'm set free
[Music]
that I am
set free
yes Lord we are grateful for your grace
and for your love
love yes Lord we are grateful for your
grace and for your love
yes Lord we are grateful for your grace
and for your love
is
[Music]
I am set free
it is for freedom
[Music]
set free
I am set free
[Music]
thank you
we're set free
[Music]
we set free
we're set free
I am set free
let's go
it is for free
[Music]
God I'm so grateful
that you're not an Angry God
that you're not a God who pushes us away
or asks us to jump through hoops but you
are a god of kindness and goodness
whose love goes on and on forever
it endures
it sees through
[Music]
sustains
it redeems
[Music]
in Romans it even says it's his kindness
that leads us to repentance
[Music]
you are a good God
and we look to you to lead us to carry
us on
to guide us in the way that we should go
[Music]
for being with us thank you for this
community
would you continue to lead it
it's in your name that I pray
amen
all right you can turn to the people
around you make them feel at home and
welcome and then Christian and Megan are
going to and Karen are gonna transition
us
all right
well I get the pleasure of introducing
our guest speakers for tonight this is a
historic evening because we have not one
speaker but two double the fun double
the fun this is Christian and Megan gray
Herring and they've been going to the
table for just about a year like almost
to the week
so you too could be up here in a year
but Megan and Christian are amazing I've
Loved getting to know them over this
past year they have just dived right in
they lead our 20-somethings Meetup that
gets together for brunch once a month
um and uh they've also served in several
different capacities here at the table
and one of the things that I admire
about them and that is a real high value
for them is the value for team and that
is evident in tonight we're going to
hear from both of them not just one of
them and also even in your names that's
a team effort right Herring
um not hyphenated by the way
combined combined so I don't want to
talk any longer because you're really
going to want to hear from them tonight
so can you give them a warm welcome
hello everyone
so just kind of to set up not
necessarily the ground rules but kind of
what's going to happen here is that
Megan and I are going to let you in on a
little marital debate that we have we're
going to kind of tag team back and forth
so we're gonna
take turns up here
um and I'm excited to share with what
share with you guys what we're going to
share
um I am uh this is probably the nicest I
have ever dressed for church I'm used to
dressing well here
I'm used to dressing in uh one of the
Pug shirts that Megan buys me because
it's our like joke and because we don't
have any pugs and shorts so I brought
out my church and jeans for you guys so
I can look all nice yeah
um okay so sometimes in a marriage there
are debates that stick with a couple
over many years
like things that I'm clearly right about
like how bad pickles are pickles are
like the most disgusting thing they're
awful awful awful
or who's the best Batman of course you
know it's anybody but Christian Bale
so but
but there are more significant
discussions that we've had like bad
generational habits like when Megan came
into my life
I realized
there were habits that I had grown up
with or encountered they were
problematic and so having somebody from
an outside perspective could help me
understand things about that or when
we're dealing with a family crisis we
have different ways that we both deal
with a family crisis and so that creates
a debate between us
and so one of the debates
that we have had is
um we're a little kind of super
theologically nerdy in our relationship
that's actually something that we bonded
over
um before we ever met when we were like
chatting online on
um doing uh okay Cupid to find each
other we we spoke a lot about
theological stuff and so we want to let
you guys in on a weird interesting
debate that we tend to have because we
have these kind of quasi-heretical
theological debates this one isn't
particularly heretical by the way
um
so the question that we want to answer
is is God Transcendent which I will
Define these terms or is God intimate or
both or how much does that matter to us
I first remember this being a discussion
that Megan and I had uh when she wanted
to check out a local Episcopal Church in
the area
we used to do this thing most months
that we called sexy Sabbath
don't ask any questions
um and every few months we would go to
this local Episcopal Church for Megan to
get her liturgy fix
she would comment about how much she
loved liturgy liturgy along with the
smells and bells of the Episcopal Church
it would convey to her the bigness of
God God being Grand
this concept of bigness is called
let's see sorry this concept of bigness
is
something that never made sense to me
maybe it was from a place of privilege
or being
raised in like non-denominational
charismatic circles but I never hungered
or thought anything about needing God's
bigness
but as that vomit inducing phrase says
happy wife happy life
I thought what would it hurt to let
Megan get her liturgy fix so we ended up
going
the bigness of God is known as
Transcendence
it is the feeling that God is big
powerful capable of doing anything
it is seen in the creation of the cosmos
the glory of the Grand Canyon and the
intricacy in which God knit together DNA
it can also be seen in the Grandeur of
the body of Christ
people from all walks and backgrounds
serving and worshiping the same God
for some it brings about a feeling of ah
of reverence and an overwhelming welding
and overwhelming feeling of being minute
or small
but in a good way I guess
I'm more naturally connect with the idea
of intimacy or if you want to be all big
and Theological like my wife likes to be
the word imminence
the idea of imminence is that God is
with us alongside us
God enters into our mess understands our
emotions and wants us to and wants to be
with us even though we are messy
creatures
he is not above us but with us
unfortunately for me the Bible is
replete with both pictures of God
so my wife will fill you in on her part
of the story
so in may we took a trip to uh New
Mexico and we stayed a couple days in
this Canyon and one night there was this
really big thunderstorm and a lightning
would crack and the Thunder would Echo
across the sides of the canyon and it
seemed to even like make the sound
louder than it actually ever was it was
huge it was big and it resonated with me
because I liked the idea that even as
powerful as that lightning bolt was to
create that ginormous sound there was a
Creator out there who was even more
powerful than that that was awesome
and so we see this powerful Creator God
in the very beginning in Genesis 1. so
let's read it says in the beginning God
created the heavens and the Earth
now the Earth was formless and empty
Darkness was over the surface of the
deep and the spirit of God was hovering
over the waters and God said let there
be light and there was light
so the beautiful poetry continues and
describes the rest of creation but the
Jewish writers described this Mighty and
magnificent this powerful God who tames
the watery chaos he's not bound by
natural laws instead he creates and he
establishes those very laws of nature
in the Psalms we also see examples of
God as Creator so for example in Psalm
74 it describes God as it was you who
split open the Sea by your power you
broke the heads of the monster and the
waters he was you who crushed the heads
of the Leviathan gave it as food to the
creatures of the desert it was you who
opened up Springs and streams you dried
up ever flowing Rivers the day is yours
and yours also the night you establish
the Sun and Moon it was you who set the
boundaries of the earth you made both
summer and winter
y'all that's epic like God is clearly
above creation and all that he created
Thomas the Odin put it this way God's
Transcendence means that God is
independent of and distinct from nature
humanity and the Material World At Large
Transcendence means that God exists
beyond our ability to comprehend fully
because God is Supernatural while
humanity and nature are a part of the
natural order
accounts of God's Transcendence his
bigness stretches all the way across
scripture so bear with me as we take a
peek at a little bit of this Arc
with Moses we see a God who can't be
contained yet reveals himself in this
Burning fiery Bush here's the cries of
his people and supernaturally battles to
rescue them whose presence is so bold
that it leaves Moses's face glowing
then in the Psalms we read songs that
are exclaiming God's greatness and power
we get to the prophets we read of
commissionings like that of Isaiah where
God is so big his robe fills the temple
and he is flanked By Angels who are
declaring his greatness
um and then we get to the Gospels
and Jesus he Echoes those calls in the
prophets of against oppression and abuse
and Jesus models what it is to exhibit
radical compassion towards people who
are powerless who are marginalized and
he even dared to forgive sins
he even shown so bright at the
Transfiguration that there was mighty
light for Peter James and John
we get to the letters the author of
Colossians writes for he has rescued us
for the Dominion of darkness and brought
us into the kingdom of the sun he loves
in whom we have Redemption and the
Forgiveness of sins
and then our sacred text ends with this
imagery of a new Garden where God's
bigness shines so bright it lights the
city
I am drawn to this powerful image of a
God who loves us in big ways who was
above the Brokenness of the world and is
outwork redeeming it and now and calling
us to participate in the work of that
Redemption
a god who's so big his nature can't even
be contained in one person but three
father-son Holy Spirit
I am drawn to this big God whose
mysterious powerful and unknowingly
knowable
it's your turn
okay as I said earlier
I'm the type of person that embodies
that
intimate imminent sight of God
I guess that's why I decided to pursue a
career of being a therapist
because understanding the Deep Emotions
of a person matters so much to me
I'm the one who sits in the back of the
church while everyone's singing songs
and I'm journaling my prayers through
God to God throughout the majority of
worship I'm usually back in the corner
with my tablet just writing out my
prayers
I know that worship is a communal
experience a way that we all connect to
that big God but to me the worship
creates this atmosphere where I feel the
most connected to God and my prayers
feel like they reach him in a more
intimate way
that's also why I love the picture of
God through Jesus
and I really like this quote that gives
that idea Jesus gave up gave up the
Perfection of Heaven to be born to an
unwed teen mother teen mom in a dirty
Barn the Flawless King of Kings splashed
down
into the muck and mess of this world he
created he traded in his Heavenly throne
for free feeding trough
amazing the god of Heaven who created
the Majesty of this world around us
and who could have left us alone to fend
for ourselves came down to show his love
in a tangible way and show us how to do
Humanity right
that concept is called the Incarnation
and it is the way that theologians
describe God lowering himself to be
alongside us
the writer of Hebrews says for we do not
have a high priest who is unable to
empathize with our weaknesses
but we have one who has been tempted in
every way just as we are yet he did not
sin
another picture of God seen through the
scripture is that of the holy spirit
that lives within us
as I said earlier I grew up in the
charismatic non-denominational tradition
and they really like the concept of the
Holy Spirit
we did some really interesting things I
have been to some fun services with
people running around the sanctuary with
flags on you know the end of sticks and
all kinds of speaking in tongues I
remember actually as a
um I think I was like seven years old
going to my dad and crying because I was
like I can't speak in
why we really liked that
um and so as a an homage to my history
in the um charismatic church we will all
be doing some snake dancing after the
service that's going to be a part of it
just kidding
um but the ultimate role of the holy
spirit is the part of God that lives
inside of us
that directs us and guides us to Live's
lot to live lives that are to look like
Jesus
Jesus once said
but the advocate the Holy Spirit whom
the father will send in my name will
teach you all things and will remind you
of everything I have said to you
I think this is really cool
that God has placed inside of us a part
of himself
that is always with us and is available
to access when we want and need his
guidance
without making this message too long and
drawn out
I think it's super important that we
engage in intentionality when
encountering God in this intimate sort
of way
the Bible clearly communicates that God
is always with us that God is always
around us but sometimes even though that
is true we still feel distant from him
um to make this journey from our head
knowledge which is the I understand this
to be true this exists as a reality to
Heart knowledge I actually believe this
this isn't just you know BS this is that
something I actually truly believe we
need to find ways that seem real to us
that choose to intentionally interact
with Jesus
for me that's journaling or meditating
singing
or doing my job
now I do luck out that I do a job that I
love I remember moments where I interact
with some of my patients and I say
something that I know is like a missing
puzzle piece for them and I feel that
like butterflies in my stomach of doing
something that really makes me feel
alive
for you you may not be as lucky at doing
a job that you enjoy in that regard but
there are things that you do ways that
you embody the world that bring that
butterfly in your stomach
for you though
a way of connecting with God could be
prayer dancing writing reading running
showering or a whole host of other
activities
I remember this portion of the movie
Chariots of Fire that pretty much
anybody my age and under hasn't seen
um but you know the song yeah
[Music]
um but the main character at one point
talks about the idea that God that he
feels God's pleasure shining down on him
when he is running
running like of all things like that's
like for a lot of us we feel the
pleasure of stopping running but for him
he's like I feel pleasure in running and
then also I feel God
feeling pleasure in me in running like
that's super cool and so there are ways
in which that aren't like straight up
just like things that we quantify as the
spiritual disciplines that may be ways
in which we can see God shining his
pleasure down on us
I love love the idea that not having to
do a specifically spiritual activity
but still feeling intimately connected
to God when we do something that makes
us feel alive
like who said
that you can't feel the presence of God
if you enjoy working on spreadsheets I
mean that's not me I don't love
spreadsheets but we have spreadsheet
people who love that that's awesome or
people who like building things like
creativity in all kinds of ways
practical and just fun
but it's about us making time and
intentionality to be aware
fact of the fact that God is there that
God is present and that God is feeling
pleasure in US feeling pleasure in the
world
I've always loved this song by this
cheesy Christian band from the early
2000s cheesy Christian Indie music that
helps me to see God's Intimacy in a way
that is non-judgmental and constantly
pursues us
so the Elms say and my times get high my
times Get Low you always let me in on
all that you know I could give you time
alone and then you'd only come and ask
me where have you been
I take this song to mean that God is
always available to be with us
not forcing himself into our lives but
willing to engage with us when we are
ready and willing to engage with him
he's not going to shame us or guilt us
when we get lost in ourselves or in our
own mess but we'll accept us into his
loving arms when we need him
this year specifically has been one of
the hardest years for me specifically in
regards to
my professional life it
without going into all the drama it was
a really really toxic situation
um and at first I tried reframing
everything in the most gracious positive
way possible that was exhausting
then I tried
strongholding peace and joy
that didn't seem to work either
and in our uh in our small group we
would share the highs and the lows and
where we saw God in it and my highs very
every week my lows were always related
to work
but where I saw God in it
was that he was my study
for the whole year maybe year and a half
leading up to this I had been going
through spiritual not discipline
spiritual Direction uh with an awesome
woman who helped me uh kind of do some
deconstruction reconstruction
processing my thoughts about God
and all of that somehow prepared me for
this really horrible year
um and in that I discovered
that I needed God who was both
Transcendent and intimate I needed to be
able to pause and say God you are so
much bigger than this really crappy
situation that's going on right now that
you can step in and break everything but
I also needed a God who could sit with
me in there
when all I wanted to do was cry or I
needed a hug he was with me
and so
my my prayer and my hope is that
wherever you are
whether you need a God who is a big who
is just who is mighty and able to break
away whatever you need broken that he
could be that
or if you need a God who can draw near
and sit with you in whatever pain you're
experiencing that he will be that too
because the mighty thing is is he is
both
it's home if you don't mind we're gonna
break and then add into communion
um
God you are amazing
you are more than we can comprehend you
are
big you are Mighty you are doing
incredible works of transformation and
Redemption
even ones we aren't even aware about
but God
you also see us
and you're with us you are present
you're in Us in in all of that and so
God I pray
for our church in our world and that you
would be exactly the god that we need
right now
and thank you thank you for being that
amen
sorry no worries okay
okay so as we enter into this time of
communion
um we practice open communion here and
so if you want to connect with God in
this way and that you are very welcome
to join
um the
the white is is just grape juice the red
is wine and the bread is gluten-free
um but uh let me do a benediction to get
us into this time
this is the table not of the church but
of the Lord
it is made ready for those who love him
and for those who want to love him more
so come
you who have much faith and you who have
little
you who have been here often and you who
have not been here long
you who have tried to follow and you who
have failed
come because it is the Lord who invites
you it is his will that those who want
him should meet him here come to the
table
[Music]
laughs
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
we're going to close out with one of my
favorite songs it's an older song
and when Megan and Christian first told
me what their message was going to be
about like a month ago I was like
immediately went into my set for this
Sunday and scheduled this song because
I'm always looking for a good excuse to
sing God of Wonders
[Music]
compasses
both and the bigness and the and the
closeness of our God and so if you guys
feel comfortable standing and singing
this with us we're going to close out
with that tonight Gary's gonna lead us
in it
[Music]
the Lord of all creation
of water Earth and Sky
Heavens are your Tabernacle
glory to the Lord all night
gotta fund us beyond our galaxy
[Music]
You Are
Holy Holy
[Music]
Universe declare your
majesties
You Are Holy
holy
Lord of Heaven danders
[Music]
early in the morning
I will celebrate the light
when I Stumble in the Darkness
[Music]
God of Wonders beyond our galaxy
You Are
Holy Holy
[Music]
Lord of Heaven danders
foreign
[Music]
father hold me oh
Hold Me
Lord of Heaven and Earth
[Music]
pieces
thank you worship team thank you Megan
and Christian what a great message yeah
it it takes courage to do that you guys
I mean I get nervous every time I come
up here to do announcements it takes
courage to do this stuff it takes
courage to walk in the doors for the
first time it takes courage to serve
communion it takes courage to be here
and be vulnerable and so I hope that
that you see that as the gift it is it's
not a weakness it is strength and it is
beautiful and I love that we do that
here in this community with each other
and I hope as you go into your week you
have those moments where you feel the
closeness of God and the bigness and
wonder of God
um I also want to do a shout out is
James still here
there he is so James Townsend isn't here
very often but Winnie is I want to
recognize him James runs our live stream
every week yeah thank you James I know a
lot of you watch the live stream first
to check us out before you come and
James is the reason why you're able to
do that as well as our Tech Team so
thanks you guys back there in Tech we
appreciate you so much and then I also
want to give a quick shout out to Mindy
who Faithfully serves us with beautiful
worship music every week and she works
on that every day whether it's practical
or inner heart or prayerfully and
I hope you get a break at some point
this summer as well because she just
continues to go and go and go and bless
our community so much and so well so
thank you Mindy for what you do as well
um
yeah so so um and everybody else who
stepped up in July
you know who you are thank you thank you
it makes a difference and we're better
for it
um don't forget to sign up your kids for
summer if you haven't done that already
please volunteer for summer I guarantee
you will be blessed in that process it's
such a fun time such a fun time
um all right oh one more thing if you
were new we would so appreciate it if on
your way out there's a little tiny table
in the hallway uh that has our cards if
you could just fill that out with your
name and contact information drop it in
the Box we would love to say thank you
for being with us
um also if you need prayer
somebody just to give you a hug or
listen to I would love to do that for
you so come find me after the service
and I would love to send you out with a
benediction that very
I love that it's on the cards you're
welcome to take these home put it
somewhere where you can see this every
single day especially those days that
you really need it so feel free to take
these home with you tonight
and you can put out your hands in a
posture of receiving or just
imagine your heart opening and
blossoming to these words
or a child of God
you are a child of God
this is true on your best day
and it's true on your worst day
so as you go into your week ahead with
its yet to be determined highs and lows
and everything in between
go with the assurance that you are loved
you are worthy
and you are accepted Just As You Are
and go
filled
with God's holy spirit
and the desire to extend these same
Gifts of love and grace and compassion
to everyone you come in contact with
this week
have a great night be blessed we hope to
see you back here next week good night
[Music]
God wonders
Universe declares your majesty
You Are Holy
God of Wonders beyond our galaxy
[Music]
I know there's gonna be somebody